This is the same problem that
we had in the last video.
But instead of trying to figure
out whether the data
supplies sufficient evidence to
conclude that the engines
meet the actual emissions
requirement, and all of the
hypothesis testing, I thought I
would also use the same data
that we had in the last video to
actually come up with a 95%
confidence interval.
So you could ignore the
question right here.
You can ignore all of this.
I'm just using that same data
to come up with a 95%
confidence interval for the
actual mean emission for this
new engine design.
So we want to find a 95%
confidence interval.
And as you could imagine,
because we only have 10
samples right here, we're
going to want to use a
T-distribution.
And right down here
I have a T-table.
And we want a 95% confidence
interval.
So we want to think about the
range of T-values that 95-- or
the range that 95% of T-values
will fall under.
So let's think about this way.
So let me draw a
T-distribution right over here.
So a T-distribution looks
very similar to a normal
distribution but it
has fatter tails.
This end and this end will be
fatter than in a normal
distribution.
And then we want to find an
interval, so if this is a
normalized T-distribution the
mean is going to be 0.
And we want to find interval
of T-values between some
negative value here and some
positive value here that
contains 95% of the
probability.
So this right here
has to be 95%.
And to figure what these
critical T-values are at this
end and this end, we can
just use a T-table.
And we're going to use the
two-sided version of this
because we're symmetric
around the center.
So you look at the two-sided,
we want a 95% confidence
interval, so we're going to
look right over here, 95%
confidence interval.
We have 10 data points,
which means we have
9 degrees of freedom.
So 9 degrees of freedom for
our 10 data points.
We just took 10 minus 1.
So if we look over here, so for
a T-distribution with 9
degrees of freedom, you're
going to have 95% of the
probability is going to be
contained within a T-value
of-- so the T-value is going
to be between negative, so
this value right here is 2.262,
and this value right
here is negative 2.262.
That's what this right
here tells us.
That if you contain all the
values that are less than
2.262 away from the center of
your T-distribution, you will
contain 95% of the
probability.
So that is our T-distribution
right there.
Let me make it very clear.
This is our T-distribution.
So if you randomly pick
a T-value from this
T-distribution, it has a 95%
chance of being within this
far from the mean.
Or maybe we should
write this way.
If I pick a random T-value, if
I take a random T-statistic--
let me write it this way--
there's a 95% chance that a
random T-statistic is going
to be less than 2.262, and
greater than negative 2.262.
95% percent chance.
Now when we took this sample, we
could also derive a random
T-statistic from this.
We have our sample mean and our
sample standard deviation,
our sample mean here is
17.17-- figured that out in the
last video, just add these
up, divide by 10-- and
our sample standard
deviation here is 2.98.
So the T-statistic that we can
derive from this information
right over here-- so let me
write it over here-- the
T-statistic that we could derive
from this, and you can
view this T-statistic as being
a random sample from a
T-distribution.
A T-distribution with 9
degrees of freedom.
So the T-statistic that we
could derive from that is
going to be our mean, 17.17
minus the true mean of our
population.
Or actually you would say the
true mean of our sampling
distribution, which is also
going to be the same as the
true mean of our population,
because that's our population
mean over there, divided by s,
which is 2.98 over the square
root of our number of samples.
We've seen this multiple
times.
This right here is
the T-statistic.
So by taking this sample you
can say that we've randomly
sampled a T-statistic from
this 9 degree of freedom
T-distribution.
So there's a 95% chance that
this thing right over here is
going to be between-- is going
to be less than 2.262 and
greater than negative 2.262.
So the 95% probability still
applies to this right here.
Now we just have to do some
math, calculate these things.
So let me get my
calculator out.
And so let me just
calculate this
denominator right over here.
So we have 2.98 divided by
the square root of 10.
So that's 0.9423.
So what I'm going to do is I'm
going to multiply both sides
of this equation by this
expression right over here.
So if I do that-- so let me just
do that right over-- so
if I multiply this entire-- this
is really two equations
or two inequalities
I should say.
That this quantity is greater
than this quantity and that
this quantity's greater
than that quantity.
But we can operate on all of
them at the same time, this
entire inequality.
So what we want to do is
multiply this entire
inequality by this value
right over here.
And we just calculated it at
that value-- let me write it
over here-- that 2.98-- I'll
write it right over here--
2.98 over the square root
of 10 is equal to 0.942.
So if I multiplied this entire
inequality by 0.942 I get, on
this left-hand side over here
I have negative 2.262 times
0.942-- and it's a positive
number that we're multiplying
the whole inequality by, so the
inequality signs are still
going to be in the same
direction-- is less than--
we're multiplying this whole
expression by the same
expression in the denominator
so it'll cancel out.
So we're just going to be less
than 17.17 minus our
population mean, which is going
to be less than 2.262
times, once again, 0.942.
Let me scroll over to the
right a little bit.
0.942.
Just be clear, I'm just
multiplying all three sides of
this inequality by this number
right over here.
In the middle this
cancels out.
So if I multiply-- I'll just
write it over here-- 0.942,
0.942, 0.942.
This and this is the same number
so that's why those
cancel out.
And now let's get the calculator
to figure out what
these numbers are.
So if we have the 0.942
times 2.262.
So we're going to say
times 2.262 is 2.13.
So this number right
over here on the
right-hand side is 2.13.
This number on the left is just
the negative of that.
So it's negative 2.13.
And then we still have our
inequalities-- is going to be
less than 17.17 minus the mean,
which is less than 2.13.
Now what I want to do is
I actually want to
solve for this mean.
And I don't like that negative
sign in the mean.
I'd rather have this
swapped around.
I'd rather have the
mean minus 17.17.
So what I'm going to do is
multiply this entire
inequality by negative 1.
If you do that, if you multiply
the entire thing
times negative 1, this quantity
right here, this
negative 2.13 will become
a positive 2.13.
But since we are multiplying
an inequality by a negative
number you have to swap
the inequality sign.
So this less than will become
a greater than.
This negative mu will become
a positive mu.
This positive 17.17 will become
a negative 17.17.
We're going to have to swap this
inequality sign as well,
and this positive 2.13 will
become a negative 2.13.
And we're almost there.
We just want to solve for mu.
Have this inequality expressed
in terms of mu.
So what we can do is now just
add 17.17 to all three sides
of this inequality, and we are
left with 2.13 plus 17.17 is
greater than mu minus 17.17 plus
17.17 is just going to be
mu, which is greater than-- so
this is greater than mu, which
is greater than negative
2.13 plus 17.17.
Or a more natural way to write
it since we actually have a
bunch of greater than signs,
that this is actually the
largest number and this-- oh
sorry, this is actually the
smallest number and this over
here is actually the largest
number, is actually flipped--
you can just re-write this
inequality the other way.
So now we can write-- actually
let's just figure out what
these values are.
So we have 2.13 plus 17.17.
So that is the high
end of our range.
So that is 19.3.
So this value right over here,
so this is 19-- let me do it
in that same color-- this value
right here is 19.3 is
going to be greater than mu,
which is going to be greater
than-- and this is negative
2.13 plus 17.17.
Or we could have 17.17 minus
2.13, which gives us 15.04.
And remember, the whole thing,
all of this, we started with,
there was a 95% chance that a
random T-statistic will fall
in this interval.
We had a random T-statistic,
and all we did
is a bunch of math.
So there's a 95% chance that any
of these steps are true.
So there's a 95% chance
that this is true.
There's a 95% chance that the
true population mean, which is
the same thing as the mean of
the sampling distribution of
the sample mean, there's a 95%
chance, or that we are
confident that there's a 95%
chance, that it will fall in
this interval.
And we're done.